>>Teacher: Okay, ladies and
gentlemen, let's rock and roll.
>>Narrator: A good teacher
is a precious commodity.
>>Teacher: That's a pretty
cool way to encrypt this.
>>Narrator: There just
aren't enough to go around,
especially in urban
and rural districts.
>>Teacher: Do you think these
Cray computers could break this?
>>Student: In about two seconds.
>>Teacher: About two seconds.
Do you know--
>>Narrator: Schools of education
have come under fire for turning
out teachers with inadequate
content knowledge,
insufficient classroom experience,
and few technological skills.
>>Teacher: And my favorite
matrix, obviously,
is two negative seventeen eleven--
>>Narrator: But there's a quiet
revolution underway in schools
of education across the country.
>>Teacher: Okay, so we're
getting a lot of sugars--
>>Narrator: A movement that puts
student teachers in classrooms early,
and supports their development
with peer groups, mentor teachers
and even extraordinary students.
>>Randy: This represents the bone in
your head, and I would be the earth
and that's about the
right scale, all right?
>>Narrator: At the University of
Virginia's Curry School of Education,
incoming students begin a five year
program by studying core subjects
and discovering engaging
ways to teach them.
>>Randy: We've got your head
is the earth, this is the moon,
and see if you can
work out the phases
by having the moon orbit the earth.
>>I wanted there to be an
opportunity for students
to experience the phenomena
in a classroom.
They have a basic understanding of
their content, or their subject area.
They're pretty green when it comes
to knowing how to teach that,
and I wanted to model how
you can start something
that really engages students.
>>What is it about this
activity that made it effective?
>>Student: I think anything
where you make the learner
like a really active part, definitely
it makes it relate to them.
So I think anything where you can do
that, like change your perspective,
just makes it all that
more fun and interesting.
>>Teacher: You find that
picture that you wanted.
>>Narrator: Curry students
get into classrooms early
and often in the program.
As sophomores, they spend most
of the year observing
mentor teachers at work.
>>Teacher: Thursday.
Can you see my tongue
does something different?
>>Sandra: Watching an
experienced master teacher work
with those children, seeing
how the children react
and seeing how the teacher adjusts
with each child, and with the group
of children, it's totally invaluable.
I mean, you can't just imagine this.
You have to see it at work.
>>Teacher: Try doing file,
quit and see if that works.
>>Narrator: Later in
the Curry program,
students get involved
in one on one tutoring.
They also develop and present some
class lessons before honing their
teaching skills as full
time student teachers.
>>Jessica: I want you
guys to think of a person
who you think exemplifies, you know,
you like the way they present--
>>It looks so easy until you
get on in there and do it,
and then you're like,
"Whoa, this is so hard."
I mean, getting ready for
a lesson, hours go into it.
Classroom management, I
mean, that is a huge issue.
>>When you present information that--
>>Mary: There's nothing like walking
into a classroom with twenty,
twenty-five, thirty active students,
and you've got to teach them.
And the first thing you've
got to do is to be able
to manage the classroom, because
if you can't manage a classroom,
you're going to teach
very much of anything.
And the second thing you've got to do
is to be able to present the lesson
or lessons in a way that the
children understand, they can learn
and they'll want to learn.
>>Jessica: And then who's
going to do the biography.
>>Mary: There's no place to do
that better than to actually be
in a classroom with
a group of students.
>>Teacher: We have kind of a full
agenda tonight, so we're going
to go right ahead and get started.
>>Narrator: Another
teacher trainer program
that stresses extensive classroom
work is Colorado State University's
Project Promise, a yearlong
graduate degree program for people
who are changing careers
to enter teaching.
>>Carrie: And I really
like love these kids,
and I finally had that feeling.
Like for a full hour, I'll
have that feeling, you know.
>>Narrator: For Carrie Hanson,
it meant making the adjustment
from the solitary life
of a chemical engineer,
to the collaborative enterprise
of teaching high school science.
>>Carrie: Ionic compounds, from
now on, you're never going to look
at the label the same, right?
So speaking of ionic compounds,
we've got this cool card
game that you've seen before.
>>Narrator: Project
Promise students are exposed
to the classroom teaching environment
just three weeks into the program,
but they don't go it alone.
They are constantly monitored
and evaluated by their peers.
>>Teacher: How do you think it went?
>>Teacher: I was really
excited about the students.
>>Narrator: Their mentor teachers.
>>Teacher: It worked well,
and it worked well for review.
>>Narrator: And by one of
the program's directors.
>>Teacher: Your transition
from the food labels
to the game was a little rough.
>>Emily: Peer review
is very important.
You have the advantage
of having people
who are very close to the situation.
It's not somebody who taught
ten or fifteen years ago.
I mean, you're right
there, you just did it.
And if you're working with a mentor
teacher or an experienced teacher
or college professor, that
interaction can be very effective
in learning how to teach.
>>Steve: So I'm going to
put up a code on the board.
I want to see if anybody
can break it.
>>Narrator: While half
of the teachers entering the
profession nationwide leave teaching
during their first five
years, the retention rate
for Project Promise grads, like
Steve Sayers, is 80 percent.
>>Steve: That is a word.
>>Narrator: He credits
the program's success
to the camaraderie
of peers and staff.
>>Steve: You know when they walk
into the room or walk down the hall,
they will come up to you and say,
"How are things going,
what can I do?"
and they are there for you.
Any phone call and they respond.
So the support is there.
>>Narrator: In addition to mastering
core content and teaching skills,
today's teachers are
confronted with the challenge
of teaching in the digital age.
>>When it comes to acquiring
vital technology skills,
pre-service teachers need
all the help they can get,
and at Washington Middle
School in Olympia, Washington,
help comes from seventh graders.
>>Student: The title's
here, and that font is good
for the titles 'cause it's big.
It's big enough that you can
distinguish the letters, and--
>>Teacher: Okay, do you see
anything you would change?
>>Student: Yeah, there's
no home link here.
>>Teacher: Okay.
>>Student: I notice that on your
previous page, like you have on here,
and that's really good, but some
browsers don't have back buttons,
so they have to retype the
URL, which is really annoying.
>>Narrator: Begun in
nineteen ninety-six,
the Generation Y program pairs
tech savvy grade schoolers
with tech challenged teachers,
to help them integrate new
technology into their lesson plans.
>>Teacher: Right now, what
we have is a couple websites
for our research purposes,
but that's about it,
so what kind of suggestions do
you think you might have as far
as wording to use technology.
>>Student: Well, like
for a presentation
about how they did a
PowerPoint would be a good one.
>>Narrator: Now operating
in more than forty states,
this elegantly simple
concept was the brainchild
of Olympia school district's
technology coordinator,
Dennis Harper.
>>Dennis: I was a former university
college of education trainer
of pre-service teachers,
and typically,
a lot of the instruction they get
are from professors who haven't been
in a classroom in twenty years.
There's not a teacher in the
United States that actually went
to K-twelve schools when the
world wide web was in existence.
So teachers don't realize,
you know, the resources.
They don't realize how
sharp these kids are.
They don't realize the fact that
for the first time in history now,
we have students knowing
more than their teachers
about something that's really
central and important to society.
>>Student: And web pages, there's
just like endless possibilities.
>>Narrator: While more experienced
Gen Y kids help student teachers
with tech infused lessons,
fourth graders help their
classroom teachers learn new skills,
like video editing.
>>Teacher: What's a transition?
>>Student: Transitions are like,
you can fade in and fade out,
and you can like a dial--
>>Dennis: More than ninety-eight
percent of the thousands of teachers
that have been involved with this
program have said they preferred
learning from students
than learning from adults.
Teachers go into teaching 'cause
they like to work with kids,
and that's what makes
this model successful.
>>Teacher: Then what happens?
>>Teacher: This looks pretty easy.
Is it really this easy?
>>Narrator Whether it's teaching tech
skills or a classroom discipline,
the new model for teacher
education is all about collaboration
between students and
their mentors of any age,
with whom they share
the joy of teaching.
>>Teacher: The last couple of weeks,
what started to happen is that I feel
like I stopped hanging in there
and started really teaching well,
and it's a really cool feeling.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org